messieurs dames nous nous retrouvons
aujourd'hui pour un thread horreur
spécial halloween attendait pause avance
à une photo de mon costume d'halloween
une note sur 10 maintenant et c'est un 9
sur 10 de moyenne je vous remercie alors
en quoi le serait d'avoir d'aujourd'hui
est un spécial halloween
et bien parce que ce sont vos histoires
que je vais raconter il ya quelques
temps j'avais fait un tweet on a reçu
quelques milliers d'histoires
ce qui est assez conséquent et deuxième
raison évidemment comme c'est halloween
on va pas faire trois histoires on va
faire cinq histoires et avant de passer
aux histoires une dernière bonne
nouvelle je suis très content on vient
de sortir une nouvelle collection
yoko basé sur l'horreur elle s'appelle
do not fear c'est que des vêtements qui
tourne autour de l'horreur comme le pull
que j'ai sur moi en ce moment même vous
avez par exemple ce magnifique petit
personnage en plastique kaboul dans doom
boulgour gueule et bien sûr des modèles
plus sobres comme par exemple celui ci à
condition que vous n'ayez pas peur des
slogans sont lourds pick up to now
vraiment blague à part voilà le modèle
de tous ordres aux yankees broderie
mignonne oui mais c'est pas tes les
voilages très content je voulais trop
faire une collection dans ce thème là
parce qu on a fait plein de serait de
voir depuis tout ce temps donc voilà
c'est disponible dès maintenant ses
sorties aujourd'hui c'est disponible sur
le site [ __ ] j'ai jamais autant parlé
avant d'entrer dollars mais en même
temps il est conséquent celui ci on
passe tout de suite à la première
histoire
la première histoire que je vous raconte
ssl d'inès évidemment j'ai modifié son
prénom pour des raisons de sécurité il
ya quelques semaines
inès en ménage sur toulouse pour faire
ses études elle a trouvé un petit appart
saint paraît pas loin de la fin qui
rendent parfaitement dans son budget
elle s'apprête à vivre sa meilleure vie
après une soirée arrosée et ness décide
de rentrer chez elles sauf qu'il est
tard et donc à plus de métro et plus de
bus du coup en toute logique
inès appelle un chauffeur vtc via une
application très connu le chauffeur
arrive elle monte à l'intérieur de la
voiture il a un masque qu'ovide elle
aussi elle a son masque qu'ovide pour le
moment aucun signe alarmant
le trajet se passe bien les discussions
sont rigolotes inès parle même de sa
voiture parce que c'est apparemment une
vieille voiture des années 2000 et
qu'elle aime particulièrement
et en arrivant à destination de le
chauffeur qu'on va appeler david
demandons qu'à une escale et sa voiture
parmi toutes celles qui sont garées en
bas de l'immeuble
inès monde donc du doigt saviez 75
chevaux avant que les deux rigole et
qu'elle rentre chez elle elle se couche
elle s'endort tout va bien le
demain ils naissent elle a un vieux
feeling un mauvais pressentiment et elle
précise que souvent quand elle a un
mauvais pressentiment ya une raison mais
les jours passent il se passe rien
d'anormal sauf qu'une semaine après en
rentrant de la fac elle retrouve des
dizaines de papiers sous son
essuie-glace et sur ses papiers bien
évidemment il ya des messages
tu te rappelles le libère de jeudi soir
était vraiment charmante envoie moi un
message
j'ai deux fois ton âge mais on pourrait
aller boire un café et là ils naissent
elle se décompose et elle panique
elle prend tous les papiers les déchirer
les jettent à la poubelle elle se dit
y'a pas grand chose à faire et si ce
gars est sur elle ça lui passera
puisqu'elle va répondre en aucun cas à
ses avances mais là la preuve que son
mauvais pressentiment été finalement
fondée et qu'il faut maintenant qu'elles
soient vigilants deux jours plus tard
enes rentrent chez elles et elles
tombent sur un nouveau message cette
fois-ci glissé dans sa boîte aux lettres
je sais où tu habites tu as dû le
comprendre alors envoie un message la
inès est totalement terrifié
sa mère lui dit d'appeler la police mais
ms refuse puisqu'elle est convaincu que
ça va me mener à rien et que les
policiers vont probablement prendre ça
pour un canular ou une mauvaise blague
pour les faire chier
deux jours plus tard inès arrive à la
fac comme chaque matin et en arrivant
dans le hall elle tombe sur david david
se met à marcher vers l est dit à haute
voix à ma fille te voilà pourquoi tu
m'envoies pas de messages depuis trois
jours inès comprend immédiatement que
david vient de se faire passer pour son
père à l'accueil de la fac et dans sa
tête il ya deux options soit elle fait
un scandale en disant haut et fort que
cet homme n'est pas son père et elle
risque donc d'engendrer quelque chose de
très gros elle sait pas si les armes et
elle sait pas s'il va l'agressé elle ne
sait rien soit elles rendent dans le jeu
de david et elle l'est c'est
discrètement de faire passer un message
à l'accueil de la fac ne sachant pas de
quoi david est capable évidemment il
n'est celle choisi la deuxième option
sall a duré plusieurs dizaines de
secondes et malheureusement la personne
à l'accueil ne comprends absolument pas
ce qui se passe
et là coup de chance pour inès une amie
à elle la reconnaît et décide de venir
lui parler
david prend immédiatement la parole et
lui dit ah tu dois être clos et je suis
le père d'inès sauf que malheureusement
pour lui elle s'appelle pas chloé et en
plus elle sait qui est le vrai père
d'inès la dame de l'accueil comprend
enfin qui se passe
de blizzard et décide d'aller
discrètement appelé la sécurité quelques
dizaines de secondes plus tard la
sécurité vient parler à david et david
se met à hausser le ton et à très
menaçants envers eux il va aller jusqu à
les frapper
au vu de la situation inès décide alors
d'appeler la police et david va
finalement être mis en état
d'arrestation devant la fac
quelques jours plus tard enes à des
nouvelles et david était en fait
rechercher pour séquestration esclavage
et meurt l'histoire aurait pu très mal
finir donc gg inès on est tous heureux
je pense on peut dire de savoir que tout
va bien et qu'il ne t'ai rien arrivé
voilà plein de gros bisous à toi et
merci d'avoir partagé cette histoire qui
j'espère n'arrivera plus jamais
alors la deuxième histoire que je vais
vous raconter c'est celle de matthias au
moment des faits mathias vient d'avoir
son bac il a 18 ans et vient d'emménager
dans un nouvel appartement à limoges un
soir mathias vient de vivre une soirée
étudiante beaucoup trop arrosée et
rentrent avec grande difficulté chez lui
puisqu'il est ivre mort mathias
instinctivement appuyé sur la poignée et
la porte s'ouvre comme il est raide mort
il dit qu'il a tout simplement oublié de
la verrouiller à claix il se pose pas de
questions il rentre dans son appartement
il ferme la porte derrière lui il
atteint sa chambre et s'effondre dans
son lit mais il ya un truc qui me
dérange c'est que l'odeur est pas comme
d'habitude
mais comme il est ivre mort il va pas
creuser plus que ça il va préférer de
dormir le lendemain matin mathias se
réveille énorme mal de crâne évidemment
il est en pleine gueule de bois et
constate que son lit n'est pas du tout à
la bonne place et qu'en fait il n'est
pas du tout dans sa chambre et tombe sur
un mec qu'à 25 ans et qui lui demande
s'il a bien dormi et s'il veut boire un
truc et la mathias comprend qu'en fait
il n'a pas dormi chez lui il s'est
trompé des tâches et il est allé dans
l'appartement de quelqu'un d'autre qui
avait pas fermé la porte à clé et donc
il a pu rentrer chez lui donc il savait
pas mais les appartements ont exactement
la même structure genre tous les apparts
on la chambre même endroit le salon au
même endroit etc bref il est face à ce
mec est premier truc qui fait évidemment
c'est qu'il s'excuse et qui lui dit que
il paraît qu'il est vraiment désolé que
s'est trompé d'appartement
le gars en face très cool lui dit qu'il
a absolument aucun souci que ça arrive
de rentrer colisée ne se foirer et qui
va lui préparer un petit café mathias à
ce moment-là y comprends pas trop parce
qu'il se dit battant moi à la place de
ce mec jour il somme tient de l'inconnu
qui vient dormir chez moi
casse toi mais au vu de la réaction du
gard il veut pas le vexer il décide de
prendre un café avec lui et précise que
le moment était un peu krings puisque
bas ils sont pas du tout parlé c'était
juste face à face en train de branches à
café et qu'aussitôt le café terminé il
est vite monté à l'étagé au dessus pour
rentrer chez lui le lendemain soir une
fois la gueule de bois bien derrière lui
matyassy sorte son appartement pour
descendre ses poubelles et il entend
quelqu'un ouvrir la porte de
l'appartement en dessous le sien donc
l'appartement dans lequel il a dormi par
mégarde et décide de vite descendre pour
reparler à ce gala et revenir sur ce qui
s'est passé est une nouvelle fois lui
présenter ses excuses parce que mathias
vit pas forcément bien le fait d'avoir
dormi chez un inconnu sans son
autorisation
il arrive donc devant la porte du gua et
toc et là surprise c'est pas un gars qui
ouvre c'est une fille mathias une
demande si son copain ou son colocataire
et là puisqu'il aimerait lui parler mais
la fille qu'il en face de lui lui répond
qu'elle n'a ni copain ni colocataires
puisqu'elle vit seule
mathias lecomte
en bas il lui explique du coup les
événements du fameux soir où il est
rentré ivre mort et se souvient de la
tasse dans laquelle la bulle café et
c'est une hta starbucks verte
il demande donc à la fille qu'il a en
face de lui si elle a une hta starbucks
verte
après un petit silence la fille claque
tout simplement la porte au nez de
matières ce bon clairement elle a une
tasse starbucks verte et elle a compris
que l'histoire dont parle mme mathias a
bel et bien eu lieu dans son appartement
avec plusieurs jours plus tard mathias
reçoit un coup de fil de la police et il
est convoqué au commissariat
il y retrouve donc sa voisine du dessous
et non pas son voisin et au final il lui
montre une photo de quelqu'un et lui
demande si la personne qui l'a vu cette
nuit là et ce matin là est la même que
celle sur la photo et bingo c'est
exactement cette personne que mathias a
croisé est en fait ce mec
c'était un gars très connu par les
services de police du coin puisqu'il
avait déjà été arrêté plein de fois pour
agression violence et squats
bref le gars a donc été arrêté et
mathias n'a jamais une nouvelle et
surtout il comprend toujours pas
pourquoi le gars lui a proposé un café
c'est le culot c'est incroyable bercy
mathias porte ans d'histoire elle est
incroyable et j'espère que la fille qui
était la vraie propriétaires
d'appartements ces remises
bref l'histoire suivante
les gars pose c'est après un fois que je
tourne avec ce chrono et je le trouve
trop cool je trouve bon temps ouais je
suis ma petite pub entre entre ces
crimes
bref on passe à l'histoire de gabrielle
c'est son vrai nom parce qu elle a 21
ans au moment où elle nous raconte son
histoire et que ça lui est arrivé quand
elle en avait dix l'histoire qu'elle
nous raconte s'est passé dans un petit
village de campagne un peu paumé en
gironde
cette année là il ya du monde chez
gabriel puisqu'ils sont en train de
fêter le réveillon est la fin de la
soirée une fois tous monde partie
gabriel et sa soeur sont allés se
coucher autour d'une heure et demie du
matin gabriel est réveillé par ses
chiens qui aboient elle explique que ya
pas de portail pour clôturer le terrain
de sa maison et que du coup c'est méga
fréquents qui est des chiens ou des
chats qui passe sur le terrain et qu'ils
fassent donc aboyer les chiens de
gabriel gabriel elle essaie de se
rendormir l'habitude sauf que là les
aboiements persiste après dix minutes
elle décide alors de jeter un oeil par
la fenêtre et elle voit que l'éclairage
extérieur est allumée mais sous la
lumière il ya personne ni humain ni
animaux elle commence à s'endormir et
d'un coup ses chiens se re met à aboyer
gabriel se lève et s'apprête à descendre
en bas pour engueuler c'est chiant mais
une fois debout
gabriel elle entend des bruits de pas et
plus précisément des bruits de personnes
qui courent dans son allée elle se chie
dessus clairement et elle décide donc de
réveiller sa soeur et de lui poser cette
fameuse question tu entends les boues et
pas ou c'est moi qui me fais des films
et malheureusement sa soeur entend aussi
les bruits de pas et après un court
instant c'est plus de bruit pas qu'elle
entend céder chuchotements cette fois
n'y a pas d'erreur possible
elles sont certaines que ya bel et bien
quelqu'un en bas et cas en juger par les
chuchotements ils sont plusieurs à l'est
sa soeur décide donc de descendre le
plus discrètement possible les escaliers
pour atteindre la chambre de ses parents
et de leur dire ce qui se passe
arrivé en bas à seulement quelques
mètres de la porte de la chambre de
leurs parents quelqu'un frappe à la
porte
gabriel et sa soeur sont figés et à
l'autre bout du couloir la porte de la
chambre de leurs parents s'ouvre leur
père est réveillé et leurs demandes en
les voyant ce qu'elles font de booster
si le père de gabriel allume sa lampe
torche et entrouvre la porte
l'inconnu qui toqué à leur porte est un
homme habillé en blanc mais quelques
mètres derrière lui il ya deux autres
personnes une femme et un homme
l'homme qui vient toquer à la porte
explique au père de gabriel que sa
voiture bien tombé en panne un peu plus
haut dans les bois et que son ami
derrière lui a bu beaucoup d'alcool et
qu'il faut vite qui la ramène chez elle
et lui demande donc si il est disponible
pour les ramener chez eux
le père de gabriel lui explique qu'il
n'a pas le permis gros mytho et leur
donne la position de la cabine
téléphonique fonctionnelle la plus
proche sauf que l'inconnu mais son pied
dans l'ouverture et lui répond qu'il ne
connaissent absolument pas l'endroit et
qu'ils ne vont certainement pas trouvé
ladite cabine le père de gabriel
comprend qui est dans la merde et
l'homme qui était quelques mètres
derrière l'inconnu cette fois s'avance
vers gabriel et saisi le bras de son ami
et lui dit qu'ils se débrouilleront et
qu'il faut y aller ces trois personnes
heureusement s'en vont et s'éloigne de
la maison de gabriel et une fois parti
le père de gabriel après avoir
évidemment fermé la porte à quadruple
tous demandent aux deux soeurs d'aller
se coucher leur explique que c'est fini
c'est le lendemain les uns photos et les
infos explique que le corps d'un homme a
été retrouvé à son domicile et qu'il
avait été frappé à mort les voisins en
appelant la police ont pu donner des
détails puisqu'ils ont vu trois
personnes sortir de cette maison dont
une en tenue blanche
donc en fait le mec qu'a toquer chez
gabriel ce soir-là il venait de tuer
quelqu'un et comme d'habitude gabriel sa
soeur et son père n'ont jamais compris
pourquoi le mec était venu les voir
cette nuit là gabriel explique qu'elle a
eu peur du coup chaque année au
réveillon elle a eu peur de voir
réapparaître ce mec là en pleine nuit
puisqu'elle a jamais eu la réponse à
cette fameuse question du pourquoi il
est venu qu'est ce qu'il foutait là
qu'est ce qu'ils comptaient faire et que
ces voitures étaient vraiment en panne
fans ya trop de questions
mais saddam il est maintenant temps de
passer à l'avant dernière histoire de ce
serait d'horreur celle de aline aline à
23 ans elle habite en banlieue
parisienne dans un groupe d'immeubles de
huit étages elle habite ici depuis vingt
ans et les voisins change régulièrement
donc elle connaît pas tous ses voisins
bref tout commence un mois avant le
confinement en février 2020 ce mois-là
aline fait pas mal de soirées elles
rentrent tard le soir
et quand elles rentrent et qu'elle monte
les escaliers de son immeuble pour
atteindre son appartement au premier
étage
elle entend des coups venant d'un autre
appartement ça la fait sourire mais une
fois chez elle elle entend plus les
bruits du coup elle s'en fiche un peu
elle ce n'est pas quel appartement ça
vient bref elles sont arrive le
confinement en mars dernier aline passe
ses journées à la maison
son père travaille et rentre que
certains soirs tandis que sa mère elle
est réquisitionnée en hôpital et donc ne
rentre pas à la maison par mesure de
sécurité
elle est donc seule chez elle toute la
journée elle met une petite routine en
place de se lever et manger télétravail
manger dormir mais les jours passent et
elle se rend compte que ses voisins du
dessus pendant la journée il court dans
l'appartement et cours précisément au
dessus de la chambre dans laquelle elle
télétravail
bref ces méga chiant tous ceux qui sont
en appart on sait ce que c'est c'est
trop chiant ils font tellement de bruit
qu'elles arrivent plus à bosser à et
efficace donc elle décide de monter les
voir dans la cage d'escalier les cris
résonnent elle se rend compte que ça
vient pas de l'appartement au dessus du
sien donc au deuxième étage mais que ça
vient de l'appartement du troisième
étage elle toque à la porte
elle tombe sur un père en train de jouer
avec son fils et lui présente évidemment
ses excuses et lui dit qu'ils feront
plus attention les prochains jours un
mois plus tard les bruits de pas
continuer et sont encore plus fort
qu'avant ça dure parfois jusqu'à deux
heures du matin et très souvent ça
reprend même entre 3h et 5h du mat
allez une se met à faire des insomnies
elle est exténué c'est insupportable
elle se dit forcément que son voisin du
dessus au deuxième étage sans plein
puisqu'il est dans l'appartement situé
entre le sien et celui dans lequel les
enfants jouent elles montrent donc au
deuxième étage aile toc mais personne
n'ouvre la porte elle retourne donc dans
son appartement et là les jours passent
des semaines passent et les bruits
continue sauf qu'après trois semaines
elle n'en peut plus et elles décident
d'une nuit sur un coup de tête de monter
toquer à la porte de son voisin du
troisième étage à 1h30 du matin
aline arrivent au troisième étage et
bizarrement aucun bruit aucune voix
aucun cri aucun pas rien de tout ce
qu'elle entendait trois minutes plus tôt
dans son appartement et qui l'a poussé à
monter au troisième les nuits suivantes
il y à des bruits de meubles qui sont
traînés sur le sol
allez ne réalise que c'est brûla
viennent forcément du deuxième étage
puisqu'elle pourrait pas entendre des
bruits de meubles déplacer aussi
distinctement si ça se passait dans
l'appartement du 3
ème étage elle comprend alors que la
journée les briquets longtemps c'est
bien les enfants du troisième étage mais
que la nuit s'est pas et elle décide
donc de monter discrètement au deuxième
étage pour être sûre et certaine que ça
vient bel et bien de l'appartement de
son voisin du dessus elle arrive au
deuxième étage elle est dans le noir
accroupis en chaussettes elle se
concentre sur le moindre bruit qu'ils
pouvaient venir de derrière la porte
mais rien aucun bruit elle dit alors
qu'elle est complètement parano elle se
demande ce qu'elle est en train de faire
accroupis dans cette cage d'escalier
elle se relève donc pour partir et là
bingo elle entend des bruits de meubles
qui sont déplacés venant de son voisin
du deuxième étage elle décide donc de
retourner dans son appartement
mais en arrivant dans son couloir au
premier étage elle entend la porte de la
cage d'escalier du deuxième étage
s'ouvrir elle se dépêche alors de
rentrer dans son appartement et
verrouille sa porte d'entrée derrière m
à ce moment là elle est terrifiée elle
est convaincue que son voisin l'a
surpris en train de l'espionner et qu'il
en a après elle elle se dirige vers sa
chambre pour prendre son portable et
appelé son copain lorsque quelqu'un
toque à la porte
aline retourne vers sa porte d'entrée en
étant la plus silencieuse possible et
elle regarde dans l'oeil et de sa porte
et elle voit rien il fait tout noir mais
d'un coup elle entend quelqu'un toucher
à sa serrure aline est terrifiée elle
veut être sûr que la personne ne puisse
pas rentrer chez elle donc elle saisit
ses clés et les rendent dans la serrure
et c'est là qu'elle entendait pas qu'ils
s'en vont et la porte de la cage
d'escalier qui se ferme
en fait quand elle a regardé dans l'oeil
et il y avait bel et bien quelqu'un qui
était à quelques centimètres d'elle de
l'autre côté de la porte sauf que là
personne n'a pas allumé la lumière du
couloir parce qu'elle ne voulait pas
être vu aline restant bull contre la
porte
elle réfléchit un moment elle se dit que
le meilleur truc à faire dans cette
situation c'est d'aller dans sachant
prendre son téléphone et d'appeler la
police pour leur expliquer ce qui vient
de se passer
elle se dirige alors vers sa chambre
lorsqu'elle entend un énorme louis
résonnait quelqu'un vient de tomber sur
du gravier aline reste immobile et elle
réfléchit tous les appartements du
premier étage sont communs à une grande
terrasse et cette terrasse elle est
recouverte de gravier quelqu'un vient
donc de sauter d'un étage supérieur et
d'atterrir sur cette fameuse terrasse
tout proche du salon d'aline à en juger
par le bruit que ça à faire allez une
prend son courage à deux mains et court
jusqu'à sa chambre elle ferme la porte
prend son téléphone et
sa poche elle ouvre la fenêtre et saute
elle a mal aux chevilles à
l'atterrissage mais tout va bien
elle est donc dans la rue sur laquelle
donne sa chambre et elle tape le sprint
de sa vie elle a eu tellement peur
qu'elle s'est cachée sous une voiture
garée le temps d'appeler la police et
qu'ils arrivent sur les lieux
en arrivant à leur a expliqué la
situation ils ont décidé de l'emmener au
commissariat pour prendre sa déposition
et le lendemain ils ont appelé le
propriétaire de l'appartement du
deuxième étage qui leur a expliqué que
l'appartement n'était actuellement pas
louer la police a donc pu rentrer dans
cet appartement et tout était en bordel
tout était dégueulasse
en revanche personne n'était là au
moment où je vous raconte l'histoire
d'aline
ils savent toujours pas qui étaient là
sauf que le proprio lui a dit aux
policiers être convaincu que la personne
qui se trouvait là c'était l'ancien baby
sitter de son enfant apparemment le
proprio il avait licencié ce baby sitter
juste avant le confinement et le gall
avait menacé de fou et après avoir
menacé il avait refusé de lui rendre le
double des clés est le propriétaire a
pas jugé nécessaire de changer la
serrure puisque plus personne ne vivait
là bref après cette nuit-là alimentant
des toujours les enfants courir écriée
la journée par contre il ya plus jamais
eu de bruit la nuit et ben ali je veux
dire un truc tu as un courage incroyable
on en parle du soldat du 1er et aline
maintenant il faut faire du décathlon
c'est l'étape suivante
à l'essai moment la dernière histoire
banale histoire elle va faire frissonner
les parents la seconde des enfants les
autres les badauds si vous en faites pas
mais les parents un poil plus cette
histoire c'est celle du père de la
personne qui nous la raconte
cynthia père qu'on va appeler john
l'histoire a lieu au début des années
2000 et à cette époque
s'il tient à 7 ans et sa petite soeur en
a quatre cynthia et sa famille à cette
époque là ils vivent dans un appartement
au sein d'une résidence hyper familiale
l'ambiance est tellement clean que tous
les enfants vont jouer ensemble au
milieu de la résidence dans le parc sans
surveillance en gros les parents ils
ajustent leurs fenêtres ouvertes et
s'ils entendent que ça crée un peu trop
ils vont à la fenêtre et idées à leurs
enfants de se calmer cynthia et à
l'école sauf que sa petite soeur roxane
est malade et donc elle est restée à
l'appartement et avec elle son père qui
a pris un jour de congé pour veiller sur
elle
apparemment roxane avait beaucoup de
fièvre elle était vraiment pas bien et
elle avait très envie de voir un film
sauf qu'on est au début des années 2000
c'est à dire qu'il ya pas youtube
netflix tout ça ça n'existe pas à
l'époque si tu veux voir un film
il faut aller en louer au vidéo club il
se demande s'il peut se permettre de
laisser roxane seuls deux minutes à
peine le temps juste de foncer au vidéo
club et de revenir et finalement après
avoir passé un coup de fil au magasin
pour être sûr qu'ils avaient bien en
stock le film que roxanne avait choisi
de regarder il décide de yale il voit
pas ce qui peut arriver à roxane étant
donné qu'elle est complètement cloué au
lit et qu'en plus il ya le chien c'est
un chien énorme qui par conséquent est
très dissuasif
il assure donc la sécurité de
l'appartement et des enfants bref jones
hors de l'appartement ferme la porte
d'entrée la verrouille le tout après
avoir bien entendu rappeler à roxane de
ne pas ouvrir à des inconnus trois
minutes plus tard john est de retour dvd
en main dans le hall de l'immeuble et
ils entendent les aboiements et des
entendants dans le couloir il voit sa
porte d'entrée et reste sans voix
il voit un mec en train de lutter contre
son chien et il constate aussi que
roxanne est à l'intérieur de
l'appartement complètement tétanisés et
en larmes
john ne réfléchit pas ils foncent vers
son appartement et il attrape son chien
il vérifie immédiatement que le mec va
bien pensant que c'est juste un type qui
passait devant son appartement et que
roxanne avait ouvert par mégarde et que
le chien s'était précipité pour agresser
le gars qui tire alors l'inconnu à
l'intérieur de chez lui dans l'idée de
quelques minutes plus tard soigner ses
blessures seelandais mais avant ça il
prend le temps d'engueuler roxane et lui
explique qu'elle devait ouvrir à
personne à part lui et maman que le mec
allongé par terre aurait pu mourir sous
les crocs du chien et que donc il aurait
dû piquer le chien
roxane est dans tous ses états elle
pleure et entre de pleurs elle dit à
john que le monsieur a dit de l'autre
côté de la porte c'est papa
john comprend immédiatement la situation
il regarde par terre mais l'intrus n'est
plus là il s'est déjà barré en courant
en fait roxane elle n'a rien fait de mal
elle a entendu quelqu'un toquer à la
porte d'entrée pendant que son papa
était au vidéo club quelqu'un qui a
choqué plusieurs fois longtemps avec
beaucoup d'insistance elle a elle fait
ce que n'importe quel enfant de 4 ans
aurait faire sa place
elle demande qui s'est hélas personne de
l'autre côté de la porte vous savez ce
qu'elle a dit c'est papa elle a à peine
ouvert la porte que le mec l'a attrapée
sauf que le chien l' attaque
bref heureusement le chien était là et
surtout heureusement john n'a mis que
trois minutes à faire l'aller retour au
vidéo club mais c'est un événement car
vraiment marqué john et cette histoire
il a énormément raconter parce qu'il n'a
jamais compris qui était cette personne
et comment il a su qu'il y avait une
petite fille dans cet appartement et
comment il a su qu'à ce moment-là précis
elle était seule
ça veut dire que ce mec les espionner
depuis déjà un bon moment pour savoir
tout ça bref le mec bien entendu il
n'est plus jamais revenu
et surtout john a mis en place un
système de codes avec ses enfants c'est
à dire qui s'était donné un mot de passe
et si quelqu'un toqués mais ne donnait
pas de mot de passe
alors la personne dans l'appartement
avait interdiction d'y ouvrir et bien
évidemment il changer très régulièrement
le mot de passe et aujourd'hui même
presque dix ans après le décès de ce
chien
roxane cynthia et john parle
régulièrement de lui parce qu'il a sauvé
la vie de roxane tout simplement mes
amis c'est la fin de ce serait dur un
spécial halloween j'espère qu'il vous a
plu il ya eu un peu tôt aujourd'hui il
ya eu plein de mécanique très
différentes
on a reçu plusieurs milliers d'histoires
dont certaines qui était vraiment très
très bien écrite
merci à tous d'avoir pris le temps de
partager vos expériences même si
malheureusement c'étaient des
expériences pas ouf ne devenait pas
parano à cause des serait d'horreur mais
rester vigilants c'est quand même
important de moi ce que je remarque
surtout c'est que les gens ont des
pressentiments dans la plupart de ces
histoires qu'on raconte des mauvais
pressentiment qui s'avère être à chaque
fois totalement juste donc faites
attention à vous prenez soin de vous
j'espère que c'était pas trop long pas
trop court clément dans l'improbable
manche il ya deux heures de rush
on peut remercier clément contre le
montage bravo clémence et un effet de
plus qui doit rajouter monte à celle où
castet coup je le sais mais merci
clément pour ce montage n'oubliez pas
qu'ils sont lui laisserait d'horreur
serait beaucoup plus fade y aurait que
de l'odieux y aurait pas de visuel et ce
serait un poids plus chiant mais
n'oubliez pas de chiqué la dernière
collection yoko voilà maintenant vous
avez un peu de temps et que la vidéo est
terminée je suis curieux de voir ce que
vous en pensez puis ciel vous plaît pas
acheter une pièce ou deux où 28 je vous
dis à bientôt prenez soin de vous et
rapide halloween
dommage j'ai gâché la france
[Musique]